hey guys how's it going welcome to my
kitchen today we're going to be making
coffee cake now i don't know about you
but i just recently found out that
there's no coffee inside of said coffee
cake we're gonna fix that last week
skinny cows sent me a bunch of their new
iced coffee drinks to try out there's
mocha there's vanilla and there's creamy
cappuccino so while i was drinking one
of them i had this great idea that this
would probably go really well inside of
a coffee cake i drank all of the ones
that they sent me so i had to go to the
grocery store and buy some more we're
gonna make this coffee cake and it's
gonna be freaking awesome it's time to
turn up so first steps first i must have
read the instructions wrong and i forgot
to buy flour but thankfully
i managed to find some gluten-free flour
in my
in my kitchen i honestly don't remember
buying this
i think this might have been an accident
the purpose of this flower obviously
is not all okay yeah it is all-purpose
gluten-free flour i have to preheat the
oven
that looks like a cup i need a little
more
okay cool okay all right
three tips of baking powder
three tips
i can't find my tisps
that looks like three tips oh shoot
that's way too many tests half a tisp of
cinnamon where are you you can tell i
cook a lot around here because all of my
ingredients are fresh and new from the
package which means i don't know i'm not
sure i don't i don't know i don't cook i
don't cook i don't cook i'm sorry okay
i like cinnamon so i'm gonna put a
little extra
oh no a half teaspoon that my friends is
not a half teaspoon that's that's a lot
half a cup of milk we are going to be
using the creamy cappuccino skinny cow
i'm only measuring to see
what you are
that is more than half of a cup this is
this is this is a full cup but i want to
put more in
this one's really good okay a half a cup
of sugar
when do you think what do you think
that's a half cup
i think one egg
all right that looks good oh no i gotta
melt butter
four
tbsp holy moly that's a lot of butter in
we go with the butter
my batter is gonna die no
now you're back here with basically
boiling butter i went upstairs to change
my camera battery and
left this in there for like five minutes
so cool in you go
now comes the most important part of any
baking exercise here with
justine
we're gonna blend
holy moly macaroni
okay hold on oh my god it smells really
freaking good let's give her one last
little bit of little whirl
i think we're ready to put it in the pan
i gotta find my pan
preheated the oven oh my god everything
life is just
really not throwing me any lemons this
might actually be
successful so i don't know if i'm
supposed to grease the pan
oh i don't want it to stick
in goes our
cake mix
it's looking a little watery it smells
really good though and a little bit of
flour at the bottom that didn't then
make it
so now we're gonna place this into the
oven for
15 minutes
oh you look great
hope you cook
start
15 minutes all right so we're gonna let
that cook what's that mean
let's take a peek at how things are
progressing or not progressing
hmm
there's one thing that i have learned
this
means it's not done cooking yet okay
guys we've got we've got an emergency
situation on our hands like it's burning
on the sides
look at it though like it actually looks
like a coffee cake i forgot to make the
crumbles on top
it's all
right oh god oh god no
no
i can't touch a hot pan
what are you crazy
holy moly we are really really lucky
that something bad did not just happen
because i would have had to go to the
hospital
i present to you the first coffee cake
ever made with coffee it's probably not
true
a little chewy this is actually
really freaking good and it's
gluten-free i think
i'm gonna come back tomorrow to see if
it actually
cools and tastes good but right now
it's freaking fantastic thank you guys
so much for watching let me know in the
comments below what you would like me to
cook next and if you guys happen to try
this recipe especially with the skinny
cow iced coffees let me know because i'm
i am more than pleasantly surprised at
how good this actually turned out and
let me know if you guys see these in
your local grocery store because i
bought a ton of them and i'm going to
put these in my fridge and i'll see you
guys in the next cooking video
bye
holy moly
taking you away